your name became synonymous with
Seinfeld yeah I think with the show yeah
and you wrote some of the most iconic
episodes you wrote did you write The
Soup Nazi yeah that was the first one
right and and in writing with uh like
and working with uh Larry David yeah you
know The Soup Nazi you're writing
something wasn't that was that your
um idea or yeah yeah yeah and if in fact
it's it's a real place it starts with
your idea and then Jerry and Larry and
the rest of the writers turn it into an
episode right but the idea the thing
that that usually kicks off an episode
was you'd walk in and you'd pitch the
two of them just like this and I did
it was my first pitch I'd uh worked for
Dave for five years knew nothing about
sitcom writing but they they were just
like come tell us stories about living
in New York we've been out here for a
long time we want to know what life is
like back there you know and I pitched
uh five or six ideas they had those
looks on their face as I'm pitching and
I had been told if they laugh you'll uh
get an episode on but if they're not
laughing if they're just kind of looking
at you like you guys are looking at me
they'd go like this you keep pitching
because you don't have anything yet
right so I pitched I pitched I pitched
nothing I'm kind of flop sweating and
Larry goes uh what else you got what
else is happening in New York
where do you go to lunch something it's
some question like that I said oh you
know uh we eat at this place called The
Soup Nazi Larry starts laughing for the
first time in the pitch he goes what I
go to stay calm The Soup Nazi because if
you don't order your soup correctly then
he yells at you he goes well why do you
keep going there they go Nobody Knows
the soup is really good they put up with
the abuse and now the two of them are
dying and I'm very confused they like
that's your episode that's the one Soup
Nazi perfect yoga get out
a very such a confusing pitch I walked
out not even understanding what had
happened because it wasn't anything that
you planned on going in and pitching
yeah it was just like telling them a
story about the weird guy at the Dunkin
Donuts this morning before you know it
was such a it wasn't they should go
right there they said go write The Soup
Nazi and I went great and I walked out
and I went to gamble and Pros two of the
writers on the show got me there got me
on this on staff and so they said to
write the soup nuts and they go that's
great yeah we heard the Laughing you
sold the show Tom talks like that he
talks like a cartoon
and I S and I said okay I go he goes
just turn it into an episode he goes
you've got the shred now you've got the
the little uh the the little thread of
it the little bit of it you've gotta
plot it out and figure it out and that's
where the work started
you know and then so you wrote it and
then no you outlined back then you would
outline up till the just the ACT break
right so you had to figure out okay
here's this place that that you know who
am I in the story I I'm a couple of
different guys I'm Jerry in the
beginning going what there's a soup guy
you have to order it right and go I know
how to order soup there's George who's
uh skeptical uh Kramer we thought well
maybe he'd be a friend of The Soup Nazi
he's an Eclectic and so is The Soup Nazi
so they'll get along Elaine will hate
him based on principle and he started
kind of outlining the scenes of the
story and what's going to be funny about
it and you know there were lots of holes
but at some point you would then maybe a
month later bring Larry and Jerry in and
take them through the board here's you
know here's what it show your cards up
on a board and are you no no dry erase
no cards everything has to be dry erase
everything's color-coded kind of dry
erase marker and you'd walk them through
beats Jerry and George talk about The
Soup Nazi George gets rejected maybe
later on Elaine beats The Soup Nazi we
don't know how you know you just kind of
plot it out no line no no dialogue just
story points Maybe
uh no soup for you is probably the only
line of dialogue I know at that point
and then you know in the meantime even
before Larry and Jerry there you're
bringing in the other writers they're
helping you with yours you're helping
and it was a you know a real team effort
but there were never there was never a
moment at least that season where we got
a bunch of writers in a room and wrote
you took the script as far as you could
take it you went to script and wrote it
and then are you hired or are they
buying the script are you hired on I'm
on staff yeah I'm on staff based on that
pitch no the pitch came before
the pitch was at Larry's house uh a few
months before
he said to pitch some ideas right it was
my second time pitching the show that at
his house at his house yeah yeah so then
how do you get higher from that how do
you get hired on staff
well he hired me in that moment oh from
the pitch yeah yeah I I hear the
previous yeah
I I went out to Larry's house and I
pitched a bunch of ideas and they hired
Bergen Schaefer they only had one spot
so everybody was vying for one spot the
next year they called me back it was you
know it really came out of an
uncomfortable moment with Jerry in the
elevator at Letterman where uh it was
Friday it was a bad week I was burned
out I was tired and Jerry was on the
show that night and Dave was up on the
14th floor right right Jerry and Dave
had been chatting we're coming down the
elevator I get on on 12 and there's the
guy who just didn't hire me like maybe
three or four months ago didn't hire me
and he's talking to Mary Connolly the
segment producer and I'm like I know
these people are gonna lose they've
they've talked as much as they can talk
and they're going to turn to me at some
point and I don't want to talk to Jerry
Seinfeld right now because I'm gonna say
something I'm gonna regret like why
didn't you hire me
and sure enough fifth floor Mary goes
this is Spike first and one of our
writers and Cherry goes huh didn't you
do a submission for us and I go yeah yep
yep I did and he goes whatever happened
to that
and I go shouldn't you know that and
then I went oh did I just say that to
Jerry
and I walked out and you know just like
God damn it I'm never gonna get hired on
that show weirdly
after that I got asked back to come and
do another submission flew out to
Larry's house do you ever go to let
where Larry lived at the time in Pacific
Palisades this giant beautiful mansion
get brought in by the maid into the
kitchen and I'm just standing there his
little dog comes out and I go to pet it
and it scares the dog and it just wets
the floor and then Larry walks in huh oh
you made the dog pee all right okay
let's uh let's go back then it's okay
I'll get that I'll get that
so that's how that pitch started
[Music]